der psychoanalytiker anna blum
argumentiert gegen jede form von
knechtschaft und für das freie fühlen
und denken das braucht liebe und courage
in unserer gesellschaft
guten tag herr grün macht und eigentlich
unsere gesellschaft kaputt
in einem gewissen sinn könnte man fast
sagen ja und in welcher form macht sie
ins gewicht weil sie machte schwierig
für menschen erstens ihre eigenen
schmerzen zu erkennen bei denen zu
bleiben weil die werden als schwächer
eingestuft aber es ist ja eigentlich das
schmerz kann die basis sein
eine empathische entwicklung ohne dass
es bedeutet dass ein mensch dadurch
schwach ist sich verliert also weiter
schmerzen gehören zu mensch ich glaube
das sind wir uns einig ist denn auch
diese gesellschaftsstruktur und das
verhandlung von schmerzen etwas was
schon immer so war
nein aber stecken den letzten vielleicht
10.000 jahren ging es in diese richtung
und es stimmt schon was sie sagen wir
tun als ob wir schmerz nicht verleugnen
aber dauernd wird das getan
da gibt es eine eine studie von der
universität st gallen
die zeigte sogar und so heutigen manager
erstens man viel weniger empathischen
fähigkeiten haben als eine gruppe von
kriminellen taten die im gefängnis
sitzen
die so das sagt ihnen noch etwas die
überschneidung von managern und
psychopathen ist ja vielleicht auch
manchmal gegeben weil ich dieser das
interessante dass es kam er aus dieser
universitäten zentralen die ja
eigentlich
der industrie sehr nahe stehen und die
wunde mich immer wie kommt es dass die
diese studie herausgebracht haben ich
merkte dass außer der entsetzt die
einmal davon sprach niemand hat es
seitdem nie wieder erwähnt wir bleiben
also mit spannung dran wenn sie sagen
dass diese gesellschaftliche struktur
seit mindestens 10.000 jahren so
funktioniert wie war es denn vorher wohl
nicht nur vorher in sogenannten
primitiven gesellschaften die ja
eigentlich primitiv sind aber wir nennen
sie primitiv der bleiben menschen
verbunden mit ein paar tischen
wahrnehmungen was sind denn genau in
praktische wahrnehmen
naja vom neurologischen her
sprechen wir von spiegelneuronen die es
möglich machen für uns was andere
menschen erleben fühlen wie zum beispiel
schmerz ist auch als solche zu erleben
sogar mäuse reagieren auf den schmerz
von anderen mäusen in einem positiven
sinn so empathie ist ja etwas mit
eine fähigkeit mit der man könnte sagen
geboren sind
aber allmählich in unserer kultur wird
das für viele menschen unterdrückt nicht
alle aber wenigstens würde ich sagen 20
prozent jeder bevölkerung ist davon
betroffen
das heißt das wenn wir nach alternativen
ausschau halten dass wir einerseits zu
den primitiven kulturen wie sie es auch
in anführungszeichen genannt haben
schauen sollten ja wir sollten schauen
dass man nicht wir müssen präventiv
werden
wir sollten nur was lernen
denn so dass man wieder mit seinen
eigenen gefühlen zu rande kommen kann
ich meine da sind viele wege auf denen
wird das unmöglich machen zum beispiel
können wenn menschen versuchen durch
leistung ihre kinder dazu zu bringen
immer besser in der schule und so weiter
zu funktionieren was geht was passiert
ist dass solche kinder dann ihre eigene
fähigkeiten auf die schmerzen anderer
umzugehen
das wird ne geehrt sie haben gesagt es
gibt verschiedene zugänge
sie hatten selbst einen sehr früheren
und sie soll ich sagen intuitiven zugang
zu ihren eigenen gefühlen und auch zu
einer form von widerstand gegen eine
kultur eine macht es gibt eine anekdote
als ihre früheren schulzeit
ach sie meinen wenn die lehren sagte
nach drei monaten voll ein goldmann
das war in berlin es sei zwar berlin an
der gartenstraße ein erfolg schule und
sie sagten ja wir ein bisschen frech
geworden und so weiter und sie müsste
einen rohrstock kaufen und sie nahmen
ihr portemonnaie aus der tasche und
wollte wissen wir waren 29 jungs da
waren keine mädchen an der klasse und
wer würde der weinladen gegenüber der
schule
die hat nur stöcke und wer würde darüber
gehen und meinen zu kaufen 28 schüler
meldeten sich wollten alle rüber gehe um
ein roter ochse kaufen mit denen sie
geschlagen würden
ich war der einzige der es nicht tat
ich hab mich nicht dafür gemeldet
und was noch schlimmer war für mich habe
das habe ich erst viel später verstand
die meisten dieser jungs kam als
familien die waren entweder
sozialdemokraten und kommunisten die
waren alle grausam
das heißt dass die ganzen auch die
alternativen formulierungen oder die
gegen formulierungen zu einem
bürgerlichen leben oder konsens dass das
alles durchtränkt ist von den gleichen
strukturen der macht ja ja ich
vielleicht ist sowas ähnlich ich denke
ich war ungefähr vier jahre alt und wir
sollten zum geburtstag meines onkel max
es gehen michael marx war der große held
der familie hatte war ja im ersten
weltkrieg als soldat und hatte einen
riesigen revolver zwar romantisch und in
meinem vater wollte unbedingt weil ich
hab's nie getan
das finde ich reingehe bei onkel max ich
meine fersen zusammenklappen und mich
verbeuge ihm die hand gebe und sagen
komm gratulation nicht zum geburtstag
und ich sagte nein mein vater sagt also
wird es nicht tust dann kriegst du alle
strafe du bist gehauen und so weiter und
so weiter sondern nach einer weile sagte
ich okay ich werde es tun
wir gingen zu onkel max ein echt tat es
nicht und ich dachte wenn ich nach hause
kommen wird mein vater mich wirklich
zahl aber es imponiert
so hab ich genau diese anekdote erinnern
vielleicht ein bisschen entfernt an eine
heutige aktuelle situation des gehorsams
eine zeit der unsicherheit eine zeit in
der gehorsam wieder wichtig wird um
strukturen zu geben
ich möchte auf die situation von
griechenland heraus
also wenn sie jetzt griechenland einen
tipp geben könnten eben auch den onkel
max zu salutieren in deutschland oder
sollten sie eher in dieser ungehorsam
ideen der sie momentan sind bleiben
wollte
die großen wirtschafts nobelpreisträger
wie krugman und steglitz die
unterstützung aller was vor sich geht
jetzt mit der neuen griechischen
regierung
und ich denke die haben recht und die
versuchen ja das sparprogramm der euro
zurückzuhalten
ich denke die haben recht was zählt ist
der mensch nicht nur einfach der profit
sondern sei es in deutschland müsste
mehr im partie haben glichen dann gegen
ja ok hoffentlich hört dass frau merkel
ich glaube wichtig wir müssen nochmal zu
von der angst sprechen weil das scheint
mir ja wirklich der der das eigentliche
motiv zu sein und das ist eine angst vor
der ohnmacht die uns seit baby tagen
begleitet naja aber das hat ja mit
schmerz zu tun weil ein kind ein ganz
kleines kind schmerzt und schmerz hat
oder deprimiert werden soll wenn die
mutter der vater hatte die anderen in
der familie es entgegenkommen können
dann den schmerz den ein kind erlebt
wird nicht so etwas das in kaputt
machten klingt alles führt dann zu einer
lösung
aber wenn das nicht passiert wenn ein
kind
hat als eine schwäche erlebt weil die
eltern es nicht tolerieren können dann
passiert ganz was anderes und schmerz
wird so etwas das einem kind angst macht
und es führt nicht zur kraft empathie
ist ja etwas das menschen zu einer kraft
führen kann
gerade weil sie schmerz erleben können
und der schmerz mein licht das ist das
ende des lebens entgegen
aber wenn man erlebt hat das ist ein um
mächtig macht dann wird das anders
eines ihrer lieblings zitate wenn ich
richtig informiert bin ist vom
englischen dichter edward jungen aus dem
17 jahrhundert ja in einem sehr guten
kurzen formel beschrieben dass der
mensch als original geboren wird aber
als kopie stirbt und dieses original
wird durch diese angst und
angstbewältigung und dann also nicht
bewältigung zur kopie wir fangen an und
anzupassen an was die so genannten
normen sein sollte und dann verlieren
wir zugang zu uns selber und leider
passiert das passiert beschreibt dass
wir werden dafür sterben als kopien
leider nicht alle menschen aber ich
denke auf der basis von
arbeiten die getan wurden während des
zweiten weltkrieges durch einen
englischen analytiker und psychiater war
damals ein general der englischen armee
und er arbeitet wenn wir 2000 deutsche
kriegsgefangene ungefähr 18 20 prozent
von diesen waren eigentlich gegner der
nazis und das waren menschen die in
ihrer eigenen jugend erlebt hatten
familien die sie als menschen in ihrer
seinen förderten ihre gefühle förderten
herr zärtlichkeit förderten das war
alles menschen die keine hinten sich
nicht fühlen als ob sie mehr wären die
frauen zb dann da war die andere gruppe
von nazis auch ungefähr 18
die konnte man menschlich gar nicht
erreichen wenn man ihnen gegenüber
menschlich war dachten sie etwas von der
von mir dann wurden sie paranoid und ich
denke das sagt uns etwas über die
heutige situation da sind immer jene die
völlig abgeschnitten sind von schmerz
von leiden depression auch von wahre
freude und wie diese nazis
da gibt es die anderen aber ist denn ich
verstehe dass wenn sie wenn sie von der
nazi zeit und von totalitären regimes
sprechen aber wir leben ja zumindest
hier in der schweiz in einer freien
demokratie und diese diese prozent
aufteilung gilt die auch für uns ich
würde denken sie gilt hier auch ich mal
politisch sie finden immer dass zum
beispiel politisch die rechtsextremen
unter gewissen umständen
erreichen wenigstens 18 der bevölkerung
in waren manchmal wie in frankreich
sogar in teilen von frankreich die
früher toller arbeiter war die zum
kommunistischen organisation gehörten
das leben über 40 prozent von diesen
leuten erreichte so das heißt dass das
spiel also das zynische spiel mit der
angst eine dauer konstante ist bei uns
ja etwas was mich interessiert ist die
möglichkeit über emotionen zu sprechen
weil es gibt dinge die sehr schwer sind
in worte zu fassen es gibt dinge die man
vielleicht nicht in worte fassen kann
sie selbst als sind als psychoanalytiker
auch autor ja mit je ist gewissermaßen
die sprache gibt es für sie grenzen der
sprache
ja ich meine die meisten unserer
westlichen sprachen sind wie formen
das heißt die sprache drückt nicht aus
was für fühlen sagen was wir fühlen wird
ausgedrückt im sinne von formen die
schon existieren wie war es zum beispiel
nicht beispiel dass er angst
er wird als schwäche von schmerz wird
als schwäche empfunden
ich meine sie fragt mich war zunächst
einmal fühlt kann man allein das waren
der nähe von der nz
die die 24 teams laufen und dein mann
fiel runter vielleicht war sogar ein
bisschen besoffene viele feine erschien
das war am nachmittag der wurf zwischen
4 und 5 uhr nicht ein mensch bewegte
sich alle blieben stehen aus rheine frau
dirie lief auf ihn zu um ihn aufzuheben
und die anderen taten als ob nix
passierte warum warum sind wir so
unmenschlichen tun als wenn jemand in
not ist es uns nicht dann geht da haben
wir ein beispiel von dem was ich rede
das interessante ist das empire und der
andere ich mag das sind forscher auf dem
gebiet der sprache sprach er davon dass
es gibt andere sprache die nicht das tun
was unter sparren tun so wie zum
beispiel die hopi sprache das und
amerikanische indiana die haben eine
gesamtsicht immer und sie zerstückeln
nicht im sinne von abstraktionen was vor
sich geht man sieht immer die totale
situation und da reagieren menschen ganz
anders wenn man vor straflosigkeit
gestellt ist gibt es ja einen ausweg das
heißt man bleibt vielleicht in einem
feld das wo die sprache regiert und was
die struktur gibt es gibt aber auch
exkursionen und da glaube ich ist die
kunst sehr zentral dass man in sphären
kommt wo man wissenschaftlichkeit hinter
sich lässt empirie hinter sich lässt
ja ich bin froh dass sie mich fragen
über kunst über kreativität an ein gutes
beispiel würde ich sagen ist ein stein
albert einstellen
bisher ungefähr zehn jahre alt war
er sprach fast gar nicht und seine
mutter am ende brachte ihn zu einem
neurologen weil wir haben sie dachte das
vom geistlichen her war behindert was
ihr sagt einmal in einem interview ich
kann mich erinnern dass kam aus in der
new york times sind 1971 er war schon
über 70 damals er sagte ja ich sprach
nicht weil damit habe ich meine eigene
sprache meine eigene sicht über dinge
konnte ich an denen festhalten und hätte
ich einfach die sprache aufgenommen so
wie wir sie alle tot
dann wären diese dinge verschwinden ja
und diese diese art des sehens die ich
hatte war die basis für die
relativitätstheorie gibt es einen
anderen autor der ähnliches rom
beschrieben hat das war colin wilson ein
engländer und dieses buch das eigentlich
damals so viel aufsehen erregt es heißt
ließ der alzeyer anfänglich und ich
denke auf deutsch auch und eigentlich
was er sagte dass künstler indem sie
festhalten an diesen empathischen
wahrnehmung und sind nicht beeinflusst
von was die normen sind über wie man
fühlen und denken sollte halten sie fest
an ihre eigene wahrheiten des ring
können sie auch kreativ sein
es gibt ja auch das darf man ruhig sagen
neben dem großen respekt und dem erfolg
den sie haben als als alter gibt es ja
auch selbst in ihrer eigenen zunft der
psychoanalytiker auch kritische stimmen
die ihnen vielleicht so viel kreativität
nicht vorwerfen aber durch ein bisschen
unterstellen oder sagen dass sie ihr
stil anekdotisch sei oder dass sie
essayistisch an wissenschaftliche themen
herangehen
naja mein sieg alles finden
aber das heißt das dass da soll ich
sagen und blumige stil von arno gruen 1
1 1 1 weg auch in sie in die literatur
in die poesie ist
ich habe nie gedacht dass mein stil
blumig er hat natürlich mit gefühlen zu
tun
das stimmt und das ist auch ein grund
warum zb die skizze für mich so sehr
interessiert weil ich denke es geht
zufrieden sind menschen die nein sagen
zu was er die normalität sagt wir fühlen
sollten
und die fühlen natürlich das ist eine
lüge meistens dass man trauer zeigt dass
man freude zeigt was wo man gar nicht
dass fühlt man tut es nur weil das ist
was man zeigen sollten und was diese
leute dann tun wo andere traurig sind
lachend sie nur als ein beispiel und
dann nennen wir sind natürlich verrückt
in einem gewissen sinn sind sie verrückt
im gewissen sinn ist das ja eine art
gegen die unwirklichkeit unserer kultur
zu dagegen zu reagieren
ja sie die norm verlassen man kann sagen
wenn man natürlich krank ist ist es auch
vor dem öl also weil man keine wahl hat
die norm verlassen ist etwas was wichtig
ist sicher auch in unserer zeit der
orientierungslosigkeit weil strukturen
und normen auch nicht mehr in dieser
klaren setzung bestehen jemand an dem
ich mich erinnert fühlte als ich ihr
wieder den gehorsam gelesen habe
eigentlich von von der form dieses
dieses es wie vom inhalt
ist stefan essl gewesen sein sagen sein
eigenes buch empört euch
dieser aufruf an eine art von ungehorsam
eine art von bewegt euch auch ein appell
natürlich an die jugend die art der
popularität mit der sl ans werk gegangen
ist und auch die glaubwürdigkeit des
weisen alten mannes und dann habe ich
mir so ein bisschen überlegt könnte es
sein dass heute die wahren
revolutionären und die waren auch zeit
dass nicht mehr die jungen sind sondern
die alten meister sowie sie und sl weil
ich hoffe es ist nicht nur so
ich denke jungen sind auch da ich meine
wir uns nur die alten sogenannten
meister sind
das würde traurig sein aber haben sie
eine freiheit die vielleicht ein junger
mensch nicht so hat wissen apotheke es
schwierig auch für junge menschen
wirklich frei zu sein
öfters vor sie tun können ist die
rebellion aber sie sehen sich immer noch
zurück wie händel müller sagte um auf
den schoß der mutter am ende zu setzen
und das geht natürlich nicht denn ich
meinte dass silber erhält ja auch wenn
wir zum beispiel reden über die
problematik des terrorismus das hier
haben wir mit menschen zu tun die ein
eigenes selbst nicht entwickeln konnten
weil es wurde ja nie unterstützt bei den
eltern bei den
bei dem der klima der kulturen das leben
die gegen sie diskriminiert so aus
diesem grunde diese leute suchen dann
einen sinn im leben und sie suchen
eigentlich immer wieder eine struktur
eine gehorsame struktur die ihnen eine
wie sie es nennen eine rüstung ein
gebiet so dass sie fühlen sie sind
jemand leider was damit einhergeht ist
ja auch das was formuliert wird in
solchen münchen ist eine riesen wut
ich möchte über den terrorismus sprechen
nach ein bisschen weiser alter kunst und
kreativität bleiben der poesie und sie
haben wir ein wunderbares stichwort
zugespielt nämlich henry miller henry
miller war ihr freund ja und wenn man
sich das jetzt vorstellt der
kulturkritische psychoanalytiker anonym
und das auch von terrible der
amerikanischen literatur dass ich gegen
jede form von konvention wirklich
manifest befreit hat sein sexualleben in
die literatur gebracht hat und damit
eine ganze amerikanische blüte nation in
aufruhr versetzt hat das ist der stoff
für einen film von woody allen
naja ich mein im selben moment ich denke
dass er war jemand der wirklich ehrlich
mit sich selber war
ich weiß das erste mal dass ich meine
ich hatte lange zeit eine korrespondenz
mit ihm und dann endlich trafen wir uns
in seinem haus wo war das in der nähe
von los angeles
ja er lebt nicht mehr
und mein gefühl war ich meinem ziel ist
dass er schrieb über sexualität dass man
nicht dass er so liebte ich glaube kaum
das war nur eine art fonds oder eine
eine zeit auch eine episode nämlich an
ganz früh aber das gefühl dass ich hatte
mit ihm war ja ist fraglich was
wunderbares weil ich war mit einem
menschen
denn alle rollen oder posen spielte er
hat sich selber er war in diesem sinne
ehrlich und das war wunderbar und ich
weiß es nach diesem ersten dieser ersten
zusammenkunft rausgegangen eine
mexikanische kneipe als besoffen weil es
füllt wirklich so gut und eben hat er so
was ähnliches mit mir gefühl war er gab
mir einen von seinen grafiken und
schrieb darauf für arno dem nietzsche
wohl als erster psychologen hätte
gemochten gemacht übersetzte hätten sie
nie zu gerne auf ihrer couch gehabt
nachdem braucht man gar nicht hat
ich würde auf seiner couch was sie
sicher verbindet und was mich natürlich
interessiert wenn man so kritisch ist
gegenüber unserer kultur so
grundsätzlich kritisch ist ist die suche
nach alternativen
also gibt es in unserer gesellschaft
drin möglichkeiten eine alternative
lebensform zu finden die empathische ja
aber es ist schwer ermöglicht es wird
schwierig zum beispiel
wenn man ein in unseren schulen
heutzutage ein lehrer der wirklich
interessiert ist dass die schüler wird
sich selber hin zu einer kam und nicht
interessiert ist in leistung per sei der
wirt erde siebelt schwierigkeiten haben
weiter an so sein weil alle wirken gegen
ihn seien weil die eltern malen heute
dass die kinder müssen leistungen
bringen sie tun alles um die kinder dazu
zu bringen und das nicht nur
interessante sollte eigentlich aber
vielleicht darf ich sie fragen ja weil
henry miller hat durch diese berühmte
schule die sommerhits cool finanziell
unterstützt als eine schule wo kein
zwang herrscht ja ja ja
also ist das etwas was sie miteinander
diskutiert haben oder wo sein einander
eigentlich ein echter schritt hätte weil
ich würde denken wir hatten ähnliche
gefühle darüber und wenn man so sagt die
schule als als zwangs anstalt wenn man
so will
es gibt ja eine zwangs anstalt par
excellence das ist das gefängnis kann
man in gefängnissen es so etwas wie
empathie ermöglichen
komischerweise würde ich sagen ja es ist
sehr schwierig haben sie erfahrung dann
ist die ja auf zwei ebenen die direkte
erfahrung die ich hatte war mit mary
kocsis frauen englischer psychiater und
analytiker der auch ein dichter war und
hat noch ein dichter und er entwickelte
er arbeitete in dem ältesten englischen
psychiatrischen gefängnis und geht es
ungefähr 50 kilometer miles von london
und entwickelte eine methode um mit
diesen mördern frauen und männer aber
psychisch kranken die engel ende dachten
immer leute die die mordens sind krank
und es geht darum nicht so sehr um sie
zu bestrafen sondern es geht darum uns
vor ihnen zu schützen und doch dass man
sie voneinander schützen muss so
sie wurden zu in diese anstalten
gebracht und da war kein ende
ich meine da waren sie aber er
entwickelte eine methode so dass sie
mitmachten männer und frauen in
shakespeare dramen die ja voller schmerz
wut depression leid und so weiter sind
und dass das bewegende war das so viele
von diesen menschen die sonst keine
gefühle über schmerz hatten dass sie
fingen an zu spüren
den schmerz den sie ihren opfern angetan
hatten und dann konnten sie nicht damit
leben
sie hatten keinen zugang zu schmerzen
wenn sie schmerz erlebten den schmerz
ihrer opfer das erste das sie versuchten
was ich ihr eigenes leben
unternehmen im spital das war immer der
anfang einer genesung
dass aber eine harte aber nur weil sie
mich fragen was passiert und apple
aber das würde heißen jetzt in diesem
fall dass das theater und shakespeare
mehr kann als die psychoanalyse frage
antworte man im gegenteil
und dann gab es noch gibt es noch eine
gruppe in deutschland die arbeitete mit
gewalttätigen rechtsextremen die im
gefängnis waren therapeutisch die
meisten therapeuten denken immer man
muss lieb und nett sein
das funktioniert überhaupt nicht mit
solchen menschen die verachten das ja
dann fast diese leute traten weil die
für die frau die darüber schrieb ist
heißt weber und was die tat nur war sie
konfrontierten diese leute die in diesen
gangs leute dauernd zerschlugen und weiß
ich was wegen mit den taten
konfrontierten sie mit der angst die
dahinter steckte diese nicht zugeben
wollen
und das war die angst über schmerzen in
anderen worten sie konfrontierten sie
mit ihrer feigheit gegenüber schmerz
auch wenn das getan wurde nach einer
weile konnten sie durchbrechen
durch diesen wie soll man das nennen
diesen armer diesen panzer und wie hat
man sich diese konfrontation
vorzustellen mit dem schmerz weil die
dann lag haben zu dem eigenen schmerz
dann konnten sie sich
und ist das etwas was man individuell
macht und ist das etwas ist auch in
einer gruppe
das wurde getan haben
also das heißt theaterspielen hat etwas
reinigendes k tisches sie haben aber in
einem anderen buch auch theater als
vielleicht negatives negatives beispiel
genommen weil sie sagen nach hitler
hätte theater gespielt oder nur traut ja
das was anderes er spielte ein theater
er spielte posen dass es völlig anders
er gab sich wie soll ich das beschreiben
ergab sich in posen anleihen der stärke
was er wirklich fühlt war völlig ganz
anders da gibt es eine beschreibung von
einem früheren gauleiter krebs visa von
hamburg der darin nationale
nationalsozialismus den sozialismus teil
herz nahm wurde am ende raus geschmissen
trotz der partei aber er beschreibt wie
er einmal für ich war 27
in hamburg hitler die fahnen brachte
seine rede
er beschreibt ihn wie er kam ins hotel
und da war hitler schlürfte eine
gemüsesuppe
er sagt er wird bald sterben er war
krank und die bediensteten die machten
lager witze über hin und dann sprach er
plötzlich ich muss an die macht kommt
und krebs beschreibt für dieser kerl der
plötzlich voller selbstmitleid war
transformierte sich in etwas anderes
rein dass die pose ein mann der stärke
der muss jetzt macht haben und er vor
jemand ganz anders aber das ist versetzt
seine spezialität war und bei allen
fehlen dafür reichmann sind darauf
reingefallen
also das heißt sie würden den umkehr weg
gehen von der pose zu einer form von
selbst durch das theater dass dieses
shakespeare bürger aber das ist nicht
böse sein dass der unterschied
das ist es ich will wollte nur was sagen
sie vielleicht weg von dieser sachen
trotzdem dass es nicht weg meine tasche
new york schickt mir gerade ein buch und
die des museums metropolen museum of art
in new york hat eine ausstellung von den
planes indianern und was sie durchlebten
aber das interessante für mich ist dass
diese männer und frauen
man sieht es in ihren gesichtern die
leute die sie waren waren nicht nur
posen
sie waren das wie sie sich präsentiert
fotografien auf ford oder fühlen sie man
sieht es in den zügen
hitler war ganz was anderes zum beispiel
da ist eine beschreibung
da war jemand
wenn sie diese fällt besprechungen
hatten im krieg und ein oberst erzählte
ihnen dass gerade die russen innerhalb
den nächsten zwei monaten sind sie
bereit 6000 tanks pro monat zu
produzieren
sie werden zwei millionen neue soldaten
haben so und so viele flugzeuge schon zu
viele kanonen und hitler wurde wütend es
war gerade vor stalingrad und sagt ich
lasse mir das nicht gefallen und der
gattin kellern ohrfeige sollte so ein
quatsch ich reden und all die großen
generäle die waren beeindruckt von
hitler nicht von der wahrheit wie
erklärt man sich dass das wenn menschen
die eine pose darstellen so gut wie
hitlers tat das darauf reinfallen
es hat damit zu tun dass menschen viele
menschen suchen die pose des staates um
sich selber gut zu fühlen so passiert
dass das leute wie hitler an die macht
kam
denn es wäre nicht dafür dass menschen
bereit sind dann solche hochzuspielen
sehen würde sie nicht passieren
und noch mal wirklich an der mann der
das beschrieb war schon im jahr 15 50
der beute beschrieb dass die freiwillige
knechtschaft
das ist nicht neu was ich sage wenn wenn
man ein bisschen auch ziemlich sein darf
wenn man sagt dass die politik ja oft
von der pose lebt und wie gibt es denn
beispiele von politikern die diese durch
pose doch sprechen oder ja die würde ich
so haben sie ein beispiel wollte der
mann der so 2 die sofort kommen
es ist natürlich frankl in der lage
große welt dann aber im linken zwei
amerikaner europäer kommen ihnen keinen
doch der schwedische der ermordet wurde
der roller von von vaclav havels spricht
man ja auch wenn man ja ins amt kommt
ein paar tischen politiker spricht es
gibt in der schweiz diese berühmte rede
von friedrich dürrenmatt beim besuch von
staatsbesuch von von harry und weil wir
eben auch schon von zwangs anstalten und
vom gefängnis gesprochen haben
dürrenmatt hat die schweiz mit einem
gefängnis verglichen eine metapher
gezogen
sie leben seit 1979 in der schweiz ist
die schweiz für sie ein empathisches
land naja es ist etwas eigenartiges sind
zwei teile denke ich überhaupt wenn wir
sprechen über deutschschweizer der eine
teil ist sehr rigide und ich denke was
mir in meinem sinn kann einmal kaufte
ich eine puppe in deutschland und musste
mir geschickt werden
ich hatte einen vortrag gegeben in
nürnberg die hatten nicht noch eine so
dass foto mir geschenkt für meine
tochter her und jetzt karmann und der
zoll legt dabei dass ich sollte es
abholen und das würde kosten was ich 200
franken weil die gefühlten das war eine
sehr teure puppen das war eine ganz
billige puppe bezahlte damals eigentlich
15 mal so ich ging dahin und ich sagte
was richtig habe ich hatte keine zettel
nichts gesagt nein das ist es sagt mal
in dem fall schicken sich zurück und das
ist natürlich sehr traurig aber die
personen die wirklich weinen wird ist
meine tochter
und er guckte mich an diese zoll diese
zweite welle und der sagt okay geben sie
so dass dann der anteil von diesen
schweizer diese rede sein können aber so
menschen ist die gelegenheit gibt dann
dort können sie die chance wahrnehmen
wenn wir über theater theater gesprochen
haben ist ist etwas was das kleine die
kleine tragödie unsere existenz die
familie und ich würde gerne mit ihnen
ein bisschen über über wie soll ich
sagen ein ratschläge geben an junge
familien wenn das möglich ist also wenn
man sagt dass die tragödie beginnt
eigentlich unsere menschliche in der
frühphase unserer kindheit wie wie kann
man als junge eltern sich richtig
verhalten damit aus diesem menschlein
ein glücklicher mensch nimmt ja kann ich
etwas vorlesen war jetzt kommt egal ich
hoffe ich will helfen ist es zwar etwas
das eine eine amerikanische
anthropologin world small nur ein paar
jahre zurück mal sagte sie sagte eltern
im allgemeinen und sie meinten nicht nur
amerikanische eltern hier in europa in
japan in china selber eltern sind sich
nicht bewusst dass babys bei der geburt
neurologisch noch nicht vollkommen
entwickelt sind dass diese entwicklung
gehe erst eine symbiotische symbiotische
beziehung das ist ein ende der beziehung
zwischen mutter und kind oder
erwachsenen vater und kind und dem
säugling vollendet wird stattdessen
wollen sie dass diese bindung so schnell
wie möglich unterbunden wird
um das baby zur unabhängigkeit zu
bringen und dass das problem wir denken
wir wollen dass unsere kinder unabhängig
aber wir ziehen ganz froh sein dass wir
planen eine unabhängigkeit die voller
angst ist nämlich diese ideologie sorgt
dafür dass eltern in einem ständigen
konflikt mit ihren babys sind und hier
haben wir die basis einer
bewusstseinsentwicklung die das ein
party verdrängt und teer und
hilflosigkeit zu ihrem fundament macht
aber ein baby darf nicht hilflos und
erleben das wird verneint aus
unabhängigkeit und selbstsicherheit
lässt sie dadurch triebe entstehen
wollte den entstehenden turn
hilflosigkeit verneinen müssen
das bedeutet dass die unabhängigkeit
selbstsicherheit die ihr zustehen eine
fata morgana sind denn dahinter steckt
eine angst die nicht zugelassen werden
darf
das heißt dass der versteckte motor
unsicherheit und verletzbarkeit ist weil
die empathische zuwendung gestört ist
das meine antwort und wie muss man wie
kann man diese symbiose herstellen oder
nicht herzmassage wurden leben in dem
man dem mann mütter und väter tanten und
geschwister und so weiter auf die
gefühle und die bedürfnisse des kindes
eingehen und nicht im voraus die den
haben wir müssen ihn zur unabhängig oder
sie zwei unabhängigkeit führen
aber meine generation zum beispiel als
in den siebziger jahren
sozialisiert sind ja nie unsere mütter
waren die ersten vielleicht
antiautoritären mütter wir hätten doch
viel von dieser symbiose symbiotischen
beziehung mitbekommen sollen sind ja
eigentlich jetzt besser aufgestellt als
ihrer generation oder die generation
wenn sie für uns wir sind vielleicht
reden sie von sich selber das okay aber
meistens passiert das gar nicht
es ist nicht das ich weiß wenn ich ging
zu wenn meine tochter im kindergarten
ging hier in zürich
was passiert wenn die lehrerin für die
kinder
sie unterstützten die haben seien mit
ihrer mit einem kreativen dingen die
eltern wollten das nicht wissen sie
wollten wissen wann können sie lernen zu
lesen rechnungen zu tun das zu tun jenes
zu tun
all diese eltern von den sirenen die
waren nicht so wie sie es beschreiben
im gegenteil sie wollten dass ihre
kinder sich einpassen
ja und dass sie leistungsfähigen werden
ein phänomen unserer zeit ist dass wir
unsere kinder vielleicht ein bisschen zu
sehr verwöhnen heute weil eben denken
dass die kinder zu sehr sich einpassen
müssen in der schule und dass wir ein
bisschen kompensieren sie sind ein
vehementer kritiker dieses verwöhnen sie
aber verwöhnen hat nichts mit liebe zu
tun das hat mit einem versuch zu tun den
anderen so dahin zu bewegen wo wir es
wollen aber für sagen dass uns nicht
aber verwöhnen ist eine art zu bestimmen
wie ein kind sein soll
das hilft dem kind nicht ein kind am
ende verachtet dann eltern dafür darf
sie aber bewusst nicht beachten so das
führt zu schrecklichen kannst du das
nicht
die autoritär sondern autorität trotzdem
mit einem kind ja nicht autoritär
man muss autorität haben das den
unterschied und sogar in seine in dieser
schule summerhill server bestand auf das
dorf an gewisse regeln die man die alle
einhalten mussten also das heißt sie
sind arno gruen ist nicht gegen regeln
und der gehorsamen ist nicht absolut
ihr letztes oder jüngstes buch wiederin
terrorismus und sie haben in ihrem zitat
ja auch gesagt dass diese terrorismus
eingesetzt wird in der frühkindlichen
phase
sie schreiben gegen den terrorismus an
und sie schreiben für demokratische
werte kann man den terrorismus überhaupt
verstehen begreifen
man kann verstehen und ich bin nicht der
erste darüber im buch schreibe schreibe
ich ja normen krohn der schon 19 57 er
schrieb über das mittelalter genau
dasselbe passierte damals wenn da war
eine bewegung von bauern vom land in die
städte die sich entwickelten und das
entwickelte was sich dann entwickelt
über ein städtisches proletariat aber
diese leute hatten nicht die
unterstützung der gruppe der bauern die
ja ein gehege hatten so dass sogar wenn
das leben schwierig war es hatte sinn im
sinne von der gemeinschaft diese leute
die dann in die stadt ging hatten keine
gemeinschaft das was wir heute haben
diese jungen menschen die zb in
frankreich würde deutschland vielleicht
weniger hier ja
die keine gemeinschaft entwickeln können
die existiert gar nicht die suchen dann
gehorsam strukturen und leider die
werden ihn gegeben von diesen predigern
die unter dem deckmantel der religion
ihnen dann was operieren
aber wenn man versucht das einfach zu
beschreiben was was ihr motiv ist wenn
man sagt dass der mensch gut ist und das
böse ist eigentlich nur die abwesenheit
des guten
und dass dieser hass der durch den
terrorismus repräsentiert ist dass man
diesen hass abwenden könnte es ist
schwierig aber eine der dinge die ich
tun kann ist ja dass die dass die
kulturellen situationen die dazu führen
dass menschen diskriminiert sind dass
sie schwierigkeiten haben einen job zu
kriegen dass sie gedemütigt werden weil
es in andere farbe haben
oder anders sprechen das sind die dinge
die dann möglich machen für diese
menschen alle gemeinschaften zu haben
aber das zeigt uns doch nicht was wir
wirklich dagegen tun können weil es ist
eilt ja man muss jetzt haben sollte man
muss jetzt alternativen haben und sich
das alternative hat damit zu tun dass
wir müssen was tun
über die ganzen strukturen in unserer
gesellschaft die ja mit profit zu tun
haben mit unterstützung von dass das
wichtige ist nicht dass wir sparen
müssen aber dass das menschen arbeit
haben und das passiert nicht wenn
menschen keine arbeit haben dann zeit
verloren in unserer kultur
aber wir haben ist ja mit einer art von
von radikalität und brutalität und härte
zu tun die sie auch mit einer absoluten
todessehnsucht beschreiben in ihrem
aufsatz und dass wir doch wie keine
handhabe haben mit unserer eigenen angst
mit unseren eigenen bedürfnisse nach
sicherheit dieser todessehnsucht der
terroristen etwas entgegenzuhalten
die liebe wer wäre das nicht ein
bisschen ein einziges konzept ist nicht
lebe ich mein was man tun kann ist sie
im gefängnis konfrontiert man sie mit
was ihre feigheit es dass sie angst
haben vor vor vor dem eigenen schmerz
dass sie selber opfers wenn das für
meinen sie
und das geht nicht so aber das andere
ist ja eine gesellschaftliche sache dass
man muss was tun um für menschen arbeit
zu finden
dass wir in einer kultur leben wo leute
nicht arbeitslos werden sondern wo sie
einen sinn entwickeln können für wer sie
sind durch was sie tun können wenn sie
nichts tun können dann sätze verloren
aber das sind gesellschaftliche
politische prozesse sie damit zu tun
haben dass wenn wir ihr verhältnis als
sie kurz ein bisschen aufgestellt haben
also diese 20 prozent der menschheit die
gute voraussetzungen haben und die
dazwischen und die soll sagen die
verlorenen oder die bösen dass man in
diese mittlere schicht hinein kommt um
diese leute zu und diese menschen auf
die richtige seite zu holen
ja aber sogar die 20 oder 18 prozent die
ganz rechts sind ja wenn sie arbeit
haben werden sie nicht zur rebellen
wenn sie einen sinn haben in der kultur
die ja darauf besteht dass sie ein
persönlich ein sinn für sich entwickeln
können weil sie arbeit haben weil sie
etwas tun können dann werden sie nicht
suchen andere zu töten zu demütigen und
zwar sind sie optimistisch in diesem
sinne ja sind sie und das darf ich
vielleicht fragen weil sie vor kurzem
ihren 92
geburtstag gefeiert haben sind sie
glücklich war diesmal das ist eine
schwierige frage
man kann glücklich seinem persönlichen
leben
ich bin nicht glücklich über wie dinge
vor sich gehen denn der welt weil man
hat hier natürlich ängste über was vor
sich geht wir haben ängste über nur zum
beispiel was mit dem klima passierten
dass die politiker gar nicht richtig
darauf reagieren sie tun als ob man
nicht auf reagieren braucht so das sind
die dinge die eine wirkliche angst
machen so den kann man nicht sagen man
ist glücklich
ich möchte ihnen sehr herzlich für
dieses gespräch danken und ich bin
gespannt auf ihr nächstes buch und da
ich danke nächste woche spreche ich mit
lukas bärfuss melinda nadj abonji und
bern nachkommen über die schweiz dies im
rahmen unserer spezialzentrum achtung
die schweiz von morgarten zum human
brain project zum ersten mal mit allen
moderatorin der sternstunde philosophie
drei moderatoren an drei orten in
lausanne auf dem gotthard und in zürich
beginn 10 uhr auf wiedersehen
[Musik]